Would you recommend Fedbedozo or Fedbedozo to go with it and at what dosage and for whole long how long
I think this is the same
Maybe the continuation of that person's question if one stays at a dosage of two hundred twenty-two
Milligrams on the Fedbedozo do they need frequent liver labs done
Yes and no so again you should start off with a baseline of doing a comprehensive metabolic
Panel so that we can see your liver labs your alkaline phosphates AST and ALT
Oh, they're all with the normal limits and we start you start on let's say two hundred twenty
Milligrams and you do another test in a month. Oh, they're all with the normal limits
It had no effect and you want to move up
That's how you would test you would test and move up as you can
I've had people on Fedbedozo
And it not affect their liver whatsoever just because they they tend to detox it just fine
And I've had some people they can't tolerate two hundred twenty
Milligrams because it just throws their liver markers off
So everybody's different the only way you could know is to test so getting that liver markers done
Um, you know if they stay with the normal limits after you're on your dosage then they're most likely
Got to stay within the normal limits and you don't necessarily have to do them every month